another feather
in your hat
z
no g
another feather
in your lap
no
dean
no
by now you've probably seen that viral
moment from wheel of fortune well host
pat sajak is speaking out about it and
asking fans to show a little compassion
just in case you missed it three
contestants on the show tried to solve a
nearly finished puzzle i'll buy a bell
okay an o two o's
i'll solve okay another feather
in your hat
650
z no g
thomas
uh oh the bankrupt country lori have
another shot at it you can spin the
wheel or try to solve the puzzle i'll
solve okay
another feather
in your lap
no the answer they're looking for here
is another feather in your cap although
the feather is moving around
900 d
no thomas
thomas i think the wheel got laura you
have another opportunity here you can
spin the wheel
well what letter would you like a p
yes there's a p
spin or solve i will stall okay
another feather
in
your
map guys
this goes on for two solid
minutes
so what liner would you like a c if
you're a c up there anywhere there you
go you want to solve this yeah i'll
solve
another feather in your cap yeah there
you go
naturally viewers at home were losing
their minds and the moment picked up a
lot of hate online with people calling
it a fail and today in sports tweeting
that it was the worst two minutes in the
history of wheel of fortune
well that's when the show's host came to
the contestant's defense tweeting quote
it always pains me when nice people come
on our show to play a game and win some
money and maybe fulfill a lifelong dream
and are then subject to online ridicule
when they make a mistake or something
goes awry
as for that whole feather in your hat
moment he said it could have happened to
anyone since a lot of people actually
use that expression wrong and he asked
the audience to put themselves in the
contestant's shoes quote imagine you're
on national tv and you're suddenly
thrown a curve and you begin getting
worried about looking stupid and if the
feather isn't in your hat where the heck
can it be
pat says that when the puzzle is finally
solved they want to crawl in a hole
adding that viewers at home can't begin
to appreciate the stress the contestants
are under i'm afraid they're not going
to do well and they don't want to look
silly and i understand that quote yeah
it was an oddly entertaining puzzle and
it's okay to laugh at the situation but
have a little heart after all you may be
there one day and no one wants to be
trending on twitter
another feather in your cap yeah there
you go
and this is exactly why fans love pat
sajak who has hosted the long running
game show for 40 years
you are now the longest running game
show host in television history what
does that mean to you
well it just means i've been around a
long time i i it's an honor and
involvement and all that um because a
lot of guys did it for a long time it's
um 40 years almost is like unfathomable
i i don't people ask me to explain it i
can't uh but it seems great and it's an
honor and it's because people keep
watching this stuff
you